the guys at the top  who become the best when you call them  the dominators the goat of your field or  whatever it is  they don't let too many terrible days  create negative momentum for themselves  they don't do it  they're just not going to do it  they're obsessed about stacking good and  great days  back to back to back to back to back to  back to back because they know if you do  that the level of momentum created after  year two years three years five years  ten years of doing this become so  massive that the level of credibility  and success you have at that point is  probably more than what you deserve  the reason for it is because for ten  years you created so much momentum that  it goes like this  buffett was worth 52 million at 52 years  old whatever the number is right it's  worth 100 billion dollars today that's  the idea